Today, one of the major physical
constraints on computing platforms
is power.
You may be familiar with this
fact if you've taken, say,
a computer architecture class.
Even so, let me give you my
take on the basic problem here,
perhaps by way of review for
some of you.
This is a well known chart created in
2001 by Pat Gelsinger, then at Intel.
The chart tracked power per unit area,
or
power density across several
generations of Intel's microprocessors.
It tracked these up until about 2001,
the time of the talk, and
then extrapolated into the future.
So what is power?
Power measures the rate of energy
burned or consumed per unit time.
Power is usually measured in units of,
say, Joules per second or watts.
Now as it happens, the way people
used to make sequential computers
run faster up until the early OTTs
was to increase the clock rate.
But as you'll see momentarily,
when you do that, Gelsinger's prediction
was that the amount of power per unit
area would skyrocket, almost literally,
and we know today how the story ended.
Basically, in the early OTTs, people
stopped increasing the clock rate and
went multi-core.
Let's see why.
Let's look more closely at the power
consumed by a computer program.
This chart comes from real data
that one of my former graduate
students collected.
That student was Jee Choi, shown here
doing what I gather is actual science.
The chart shows measured power
taken at a bunch of samples
while the application was running.
You can see that there's
some fluctuation.
Presumably the power behavior of the
application is changing as it's doing
different things.
A computing system at some
point in time has two parts.
I will call the first
part constant power.
Constant power is basically some
baseline amount of power that
the application or
the computing system consumes,
independent of what it's doing.
Now, you may have heard
the term static power and
idle power being bandied
about in your daily life.
Because I mean, who doesn't walk into
a grocery store or yoga studio and
hear people always talking about
static power this or idle power that?
Very roughly speaking,
constant power is a general term
that I'll use to encompass things
like static and idle power.
And if you don't know what I'm
talking about, just remember,
constant power is baseline power.
Now, suppose a computation runs.
Depending on what parts of the system
it's using, the power above and
beyond constant power will fluctuate.
Let's call those
fluctuations dynamic power.
Ew!
Well, maybe not that dynamic.
Now real life circuits can be much more
complex than this simple model suggests.
But let's not worry about that.
Instead, let's take a cue from
the famous statistician George Box.